那在之前的时候
我也用过很多工作流
比如说非常热门的这个开源工具
Super powers
这里面写计划
特朗风暴和执行计划
它也是一个小的工作流
那除了这个之外
我也用过workflows
那这个也是非常好用的
他也是从头脑风暴到产生计划
然后执行呢带到旅游
这也是一个好的工作流
由然而也用过像MANU这样的
生成了很多这样的计划文件
然后去执行
就算关闭了对话之后
你也能启动
能恢复之前的一个任务的一个详细情况
那么这些工作流其实都有各自的优点
也有各自的缺点
比如说他们没有用子代理去解决
上下文臃肿的问题
没有生成很详细的这种完整阶段的所有的文档
今天要介绍的这个工作流呢
GSD呢就解决了上面所有的问题
那GSD呢是一个开源的规范驱动的工作流
那么在GITHUB上已经有差不多3万的stars
所以说是非常受欢迎的
本期视频就来给大家介绍一下
GSD的主要的作用
以及如何使用优缺点
在了解JSD之前
我们来看一下啊
如果没有用工作流怎么来进行AI编程呢
那么这个过程比如说你有个想法对吧
然后就开始让他去润色
然后呢确认没问题
那就开始编码
编码完成之后
你可能会去让他去加功能
去修问题
那这个过程中导致的上下文就会越来越长了
之后
那AI大模型就会产生幻觉
会去走捷径
然后可能就忘记你之前说过了
说要约束这个约束那个
然后就越来越笨
越来越笨
然后最后导致就整个项目就产生了很多问题
你只能推倒重来
我相信这个过程很多人都经历过
那刚刚说的流程其实就反映了几个问题
第一就是上下文会越来越长
随着你的对话会越来越长
虽然它会自动压缩
但是会损失很多这样有效的信息
然后呢就是你说的是说的对话的内容啊
是散落在各个地方的
一会说给我加个功能
一会说这个按钮要上一点
一会说要再加个验证
一会说要加个约束
它是散落在各个地方
是没办法形成一个统一的约束
或者说一个长期可以注入到上下文那里面的
固定的元素的
还有一个就是你如果没有开启子代理的话
那么你整个对话全部是在主页进的进行
这个是很占用上下
那最后就是你如果把CLOCODE关闭了
或者说你新开一个clock对话
那么你可能所有的事情都得重新来一遍
那GSD是怎么解决的呢
比如说第一个问题就是这个超长对话
那它会开启子代理
它生成很多计划当中
他把你这个需求拆拆分成多个计划
那多个计划它会标记
哪些计划是可以并行执行的
那么它就会开启多个子代理
那这样的话
你的主agent的这个上下文是占用的是比较少
那第二个就是它会生成很多很多这样的文件
那文件和文件之间不是说没有关系的
是有关联关系的
就说它会有一个总分
所有的文件都会依赖你的项目的
你这个需求的一个总的文件
然后去关联
那可以去同步更新状态去追踪
所以这个是非常重要
那这个就是刚刚讲了
他会把一些计划打好标记
这些计划是可以并行通过多个A级
那么如果是有互相影响的
那么它是按顺序提升了这个编码的效率
和减少了上下文的占用
那通过上面的描述呢
你对GSD应该有一些些感觉了
它其实是什么呢
它是通过30多个命令
然后把项目开发的每一个流程都切的很
但每个流程里面又会产生很多文件
那这些文件呢将伴随着整个项目的开发过程中
那有些是全局文件
有些是部分文件
所以说是非常非常可靠的
接下来我们再来看一下
JS的一个完整的工作流啊
这些工作流里面包含了很多命令
这些命令并不是全部
这是说你可能经常用到的
那么他整个工作流是什么
第一步就是说先初始化
然后先提一下你的需求
然后再进入一个讨论
生成计划文档
然后执行
然后再验收这个过程中
那么你也可以去创建一个新的里程碑
然后再去进行上面这个过程
通过上面这个工作流啊
会产生这些文件啊
这个文件等会我们后面会重点讲到
那么这是一个完整的工作流啊
我们来详细讲解一下每一个步骤
那第一步就是初始化项目来执行这个new project
那么对于你如果是已经有代码项目啊
你也可以执行这个项目
然后它会检测
如果有代码
它会让你先执行这个就map code base
先会扫描你这个代码库里面
你所有的代码以及一些文档
然后呢会产生这些技术站啊
你的架构啊
你的文件夹目录啊
然后一个项目的说明啊
会产生这些文件
那这些文件会在后面阶段会用到
如果是完全新的项目
那么new project执行完之后
会生成整个项目的一个概况
那比如说我这个项目是从0~1
使用JSD来做的
那么我使用new project之后啊
这边就会生成这四个非常重要的文件
第一个就是这个项目的描述
Project md
你可以认为这是这四这四个文件是全局存在的
就是你后面所有的阶段呀
步骤啊
执行呀都会读取这里的内容作为来参考
那这是一个项目的描述以及主要的功能
以及你的这个MVP阶段要做了什么东西
那这个呢就是一个相当于类似一个验收清单
它会根据你这里面列出来的功能啊去做计划
那这边的话是一个路线图
也就是说它会把你这个需求分成不同的阶段
每个阶段会跟这里的功能是关联的
然后这个思
那这个state呢
就是整个啊项目的一个阶段的一个运行的情况
比如说我刚刚已经完成了
第一个阶段的开发任务
那么这边的话都会记记下来百百分之多少
那么你不管在哪个地方启动
它都会读取这个state
所以说执行new project之后
它生成这些文件是非常重要的
接下来第二步就是
当你的需求已经发送给他的时候
就要进行一个讨论
那这个阶段其实是可以不需要的
因为我们在discuss到生成计划文档的时候
这一步可以根据情况
如果你给到的这个new project如果是非常丰富的
比如说你在执行new project的时候
你给到的是个PD文档
那么你直接可以跳过这个讨论阶段
直接就让他去生成计划是完全没问题的
那么比如在执行new project之后啊
你这边会生成的这个load map里面它会分阶段
那比如说我这个已分成啊五个阶段
那么它是一个阶段一个阶段来执行的
在这里在这里的时候啊
你可以去执行
比如discuss
那这个命令后面就是你的这个阶段的编号
就是他讨论完需求之后
他一定会把阶段分析出来
每一个阶段要做什么事情
然后你这边就输入一
那他就会去执行一个讨论的阶段
那讨论的阶段呢他会问你非常多的问题啊
比如说我现在执行的这个四这个讨论
他就会通过color code的这个ask工具啊
会向你提问
收集完所有的问题之后呢
他就会生成一个这样的一个context m d
也就是说你的一个需求确认的文件
就是在这个阶段会生成这个context md
哎
我们可以看一下我们其他的阶段的生成的
这个文档啊
比如说我第一阶段生成的是这个context md
这个就是它跟我讨论之后
问了我很多问题
那最终确认我需要做什么
然后它生成了一个这样一个结果
那discuss完了之后呢
那么你就可以去生成计划了
针对阶段能生成具体的执行计划
而这一步是非常重要的
他每一个阶段一定是一整套流程
就他每个每一个阶段一定是一整套这个流程
从讨论到计划到执行到验证
它是一个阶段
一个阶段
阶段和阶段之间有可能是独立
也可能是相互依赖
就是完全他自己会去设计好
那么你输入这个之后
他就会调用子agent的去做很多分析呀
然后这个设计啊
然后形成形成更具体的这个文件
那比比如说这些PRIN结尾的这些文件
都是它生成要执行的具体体的一个计划
到这一步其实已经非常细了
你生成完plane之后
接下来就可以去执行了
那这一步就非常非常重要
是最终的一个编码的阶段
就用这个命令你要执行
比如刚刚我们的第四阶段
那么他就会去分析我们所有的这个prime
比如说这里所有的pin文档
那这个play文档里面会有一个这样wave这个编号啊
如果编号是一样的
那它就会放到一个子A技能去执行
如果是不一样
他就会开启多个这样的A技能去执
所以说非常依赖于他这个前面的分析啊
他就可以执行一个并行开发了
比如说这个同一个wave
它是可以去同时去执行的
那么它们之间有可能会依赖
依赖的话
他就串行执行
那我们可以看到啊
比如说我们随便打开一个这个plan
那他就会依赖零二杠一
这个plan完成之后
它才会执行
如果是数字是一样的
它是并行执行
那执行完这个之后呢
那就要去验收了
那他这里的验收其实跟我们传统意义上说
写测试用例啊不太一样
它是一种人为去参与的
我们来举个例子啊
还是一样输入这个命令
我们用g s d value f
然后这个输入比如说刚刚我们完成二
它的作用是什么呢
他会把所有的这个需要测试的点给你列出来
让你自己去跑
比如说你点一个按钮出现一个什么效果
你告诉他有没有出现哦
它出现了
如果没有出现
那你就把错误发给他
他就会去进行修复
然后接着往下走
相当于在这个阶段你只充当一个测试人员
那么除了这种测试呢
你也可以使用这个命令
Jsd test
这个命令呢就是插入很多这种测试用例啊
它也会根据你的这个阶段生成的
这个PREME文档里面的这个啊验证的
这个验证的这个文件啊
去生成很多这样的一个测试用例
那比如说在我这个项目中
我就为了二阶段写了很多这样的测试用例啊
它生成了他就会去执行测试
所以这是一种两种测试方式
优先使用这种啊人为参与的这种方式啊
如果你需要去测试某个方法
某个流程
那么你是可以用这个ADD test去测试的
你可以描述你要测试什么样的方法
它就会根据你的这个东西去啊
生成这样的测试用例
那比如说刚刚我们执行的这个测试
他找到我们这个沙漠里这个文件
然后呢告诉我们要测试什么
这个它这里面叫UIT
就用户参与好
开始了
他让我先登录这个系统
然后呢进入这个页面
然后看一下是不是有这些东西
如果OK
那么你就可以输入pass
如果没有的话
那么你就输入产生的问题发给他
他去修复
修复完之后我们继续有点像
就是什么呢
就是他把这个测试的场景啊
单子都给你列好了
你就要人为去测试一下
那上面的流程完成之后
就类似于把一个功能都全部做完了
但有时候你可能需要在你的这个上面
这个需求里面去增加阶段
那么你也可以去执行
比如说像这个g s d ADD
那这里面有很多命令啊
就比如说加这个阶段
那加入了这个阶段之后又会重启讨论计划
执行验收这样的一个完整的一个过程
接下来就是一个里程碑
那什么是里程碑呢
我认为是一个比较大的一个迭代啊
那么你可以设置一个里程碑
类似于打一个标记
它其实内部执行的过程和着刚刚我们说的啊
project其实是类似的
在上面说的这个过程中啊
其实我们也发现了
就说你在执行过程中会形成大量的这种文件
非常非常细
但其实你可能有时候就是要做一个简短的开发
一个简单的开发
这个时候他提供一个命令叫quick
那这个quick就是他不会去走这个discuss啊
prying啊
这个验收的阶段
他直接就给你把代码改了
跟我们平时对话是一样
但是呢它会生成一个这样的一个quick的
一个一个文件文件
方便你后面去追溯也好
去预览也好
那么你如果去改一些小的功能
完全可以用quick去去操作
这样不要用这个正常的流程
这边的话就提供了他很多很多这样的命令啊
基本上所有的命令都包含了
那么也非常建议大家使用AI编程工具
去把它这个源码下载下来
然后呢去跟他对话
去了解它他这个工具的设计原理
他其实用了非常多
我觉得很有意思
比如说他写的很多这样的脚本
都是使用这种类似于XML结构的这种方式来写的
然后呢他所有的命令其实不是真正执行的
真正执行的是在一个根目录里面
有一个这样的workflow啊
比如说我们的new project
那么在这个命令里面
他就会去执行在这个根目录里面的这个呃
工作流
真正的工作流执行是在这里的
所以呢可以去下载下来去学习一下
在上面的过程中
我们了解到啊
就JS的很好
它把你整个流程都追踪起来了
但是其实也带来了很多问题
那么很早的时候我其实用过一次
但是呢用的时候发现就是它了解的太细了
生成的文档太多了
而且受限于这个模型的能力
有些效果是不是太好的
而且非常依赖于模型生成代码的速度啊
文档的速度
如果你这个模型生成的这个比较慢
那么整个功能完成的时间就非常长
所以我们也来讨论一下GSD哪些场景
它适合哪些场景是不适合
他有什么样的缺点呢
首先是token消耗肯定是更多的
因为它会生成大量的文件
会开启很多这样的子代理
这些都是要消耗token的
那第二个呢就是你一旦使用了这个命令啊
去开始这样的流程
你基本上你能参与的这个东西是非常少的
因为他完全是通过对话询问的方式
来创建这样的文档
然后去根据这个文档去开发
你很难就说去插入去做一些事情
而且在用的时候啊
你一定要区分什么情况下要用它
什么情况下不用
你一旦用错了
那整个过程是非常长的
还有就是他这里的命令也非常多
然后这里面有30多个命令
每一个命令是怎么用的
这个可能这个就需要你去下载下来源代码
去仔细去研究一下
但是基本上这几个就够用了
这五个命令就够用了
那最后一个就是他非常依赖于你
对他的信息的补充
因为他是事无巨细去了解你的这个细节的
如果你对项目的功能自己都不清楚
你描述也不清楚
那么就会导致啊垃圾进垃圾出
因为他会完全遵循你的意思去开发
他不会自己去发挥想象的
所以GSD我觉得比较适合什么呢
就是中大型的项目
中大型的功能可能需要去持续去迭代
而且本身你的自己本身就有很好的一个流程
开发的一个习惯
你的团队都会遵循这样的一个流程
那么是非常适合也非常契合的
OK本期视频就到这了
希望这个能帮助到你